Marc Andreessen has helped a lot
of people get rich—including
Marc Andreessen.
And he's made millions of people's
lives more fun, more efficient,
or just a little weirder.
He's the co-creator of the first
widely used web browser.
He's the co-founder of the venture
capital powerhouse Andreessen
Horowitz.
And though he hates the industry
term 'unicorn' for a private tech
firm valued at more than
$1,000,000,000, he's a famously
successful unicorn wrangler—he
was an early investor in Facebook,
Pinterest, LinkedIn, Twitter,
Lyft and more.
Andreessen is also aggressively
quotable. Whether it's his classic
2011 pronouncement that "software
is eating the world" or his more
recent, "there are no bad ideas,
only early ones." And in
2014 he said, "In 20
years, we'll be talking about
Bitcoin the way we talk about the
Internet today." A born bull,
Andreessen is an optimist who places
his hope for the future squarely
in the hands of the "19-year-olds
and the start-ups no one's heard
of." As splashy A.I.
such as ChatGPT and DALL-E begin
to permeate our daily lives and the
predictable panic revs up, Reason
sat down with Andreessen to talk
about what the future will look
like, whether it's still going to
emerge from Silicon Valley, about
the role of government in fostering
or destroying innovation and what
you should read on your next beach
vacation.
So let's start with
AI.
I tend to be skeptical on a pretty
basic level of people who want to
claim that this time it's different
with any given tech
or cultural trend.
But I guess what I want to start
with is, is this time it's
different?
Yeah. Can I. Can I do the long, can
I do the long answer?
Absolutely.
It's okay. Good. So.
So, look, the long answer is, like,
you know, AI has been kind of the
fundamental dream of computer
science going all the way back to
the 1940s. Right.
So, Alan Turing, Alan Turing used to
be this obscure historical figure,
and then they made the movie, "The
Imitation Game," which I
hear is a great movie, which has
made him more famous. And, you know,
he was sort of one of the, you know,
there are a bunch of these guys, but
they were a bunch of guys back then
who sort of invented the computer as
we know it today, you know, and it
was during the heat, the heat of
World War II. But, but even in the
very beginning, you know, they just
have this, you know, this, the, you
know, human beings, I think, can't
resist anthropomorphizing
everything. And so he had this kind
of, you know, feeling, right, this
sort of drive right up front saying,
like, let's let's build an
electronic brain, right?
Let's, let's, let's build artificial
intelligence. So he and John von
Neumann and Claude Shannon and a lot
of those guys in that era, you know,
kind of were thinking about this.
And this is literally when they're
wiring the first computers together.
Right. And the computers that they
were working with in those days,
they were running out of vacuum
tubes, right.
And they literally would hand wire
the computers together, like they
were hand soldering the connections.
You know, the term 'computer bug'
actually comes from the fact that
the problem that they had in those
days was not a software bug as
we understand it today, the problem
they would have is that an actual
insect would fly into the wiring
and would fry, and then that would
actually short out the computer, and
so that's why, that's why computer
problems are called bugs.
So anyway, this has been a dream,
you know, going all the way back to
that era. And then basically the
field of computer science has always
had this AI kind of specialty
in it, basically for like
78 years now, right.
And, you know, to your point, like
repeatedly, there was like this
dream that it was finally about to
happen. There were,
depends how you count like five or
six, like AI booms where people
were really convinced that, like,
this time is the time it's going to
happen.
And then there were what in the
field are referred to as the AI
winters, right, in which it turns
out like, oops, you know, not yet.
But I mean, if you think about it,
78 years, like there were
AI researchers who literally were
born, went to college, got their
PhDs, worked in the field their
entire career, and died
kind of in that period without ever
actually seeing the results of all
of their work.
And so it's one of these things
where, like, you know, this, you
know, it's like, you know, it's like
one of these things, it's like, you
know, Isaac Newton spent a lot of
his time pursuing alchemy, right.
And it's like, you know, there are
some things that these people kind
of spent decades on or, or even
longer and they never work, and then
there are some things that are, you
know, 78-year, you know, overnight
successes like sometimes these
things actually do work.
And so, yeah, so
so, you know,
for sure we're in another one of
those AI booms. It's like AI boom
number of five or six or seven.
For sure there's this rush of
enthusiasm.
But there's a couple things that are
different about what's happening
right now, and the big
thing that's different is that there
are these, like, very well-defined
tests, ways of sort of measuring
sort of intelligence-like
capabilities, let's say,
and computers have started to do
actually better than people on these
tests. And these are tests that
involve kind of interactions with
fuzzy reality.
Right, so these aren't just tests of
like, can you do math faster?
These are tests of like, can you
process reality in a superior way?
And so the first of those test
breakthroughs was in 2012, when
computers became better than human
beings at recognizing images in,
recognizing objects in images,
right. So you like, throw up a whole
bunch of images, a whole bunch of
photographs, right, and it's like,
is this, you know, the, use the
Internet meme, is this a cat, right,
or is this like a, you know,
cinnamon bun, right.
Or is this something else?
And computers are now actually
better at doing that kind of object
recognition in images at scale than
people are.
That, that's the breakthrough that
has made the self-driving car a real
possibility. Right.
Because, because what the
self-driving car is is basically
just processing large amounts of
images and trying to understand, you
know, is that a kid running across
the street or is that a plastic bag?
Right. And should I hit the brakes
or should I just keep going?
And self-driving cars are starting
to work, like Tesla's, you know,
full self-driving isn't perfect yet,
but it's starting to work quite
well. And then, you know, Waymo,
one of our companies, you know, you
know, they're up and running now.
It's something that people can
people can experience.
And so, so that's starting to
happen. And then we started
to see kind of these breakthroughs
in natural, what's called natural
language processing about five years
ago, where computers started getting
really good at understanding written
English. They started actually
getting very good at speech
synthesis, which is actually quite
a challenging problem itself.
And then most recently, there's this
huge breakthrough, you know, in, you
know, in the product that's sort of
come to market called ChatGPT or,
you know, more generally this
phenomenon, it's...
ChatGPT is an instance
of a broader phenomenon in the field
called large language models or
LLMs.
And you know, people presumably
like, I don't know, a lot of people
have now tried this and so they've
had a hands-on experience with this.
And I'll just tell you, like a lot
of people outside the tech industry
are shocked by what that thing can
do. And I'll just tell you, a lot of
people inside the tech industry are
shocked by what that thing can do.
And so, you know, it feels
like...
Actually.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was actually going to ask
that because ChatGPT does feel
to those of us who don't
fundamentally understand what's
going on, like a little bit of a
party trick or a magic trick, right.
And sometimes it's the sort of
classic technology
sufficiently advanced is
indistinguishable from magic, and
sometimes it
really is a trick.
But, you know, you're
saying, no, no, this is,
this is something real.
We can see something real
underneath.
Well, so it's also a trick,
right?
So it's both, right?
So this is why it's this is why your
question is such an interesting
question. Right? This is this
actually a very kind of big,
profound there's a big, profound
underlying question we're.
Going to get to, which is what does
it mean to be smart and what does it
mean to be conscious? What does it
mean to be human?
Like like ultimately, all
the big questions are not what does
the machine do? Ultimately, all the
big questions.
Are, what do we.
Do? Right?
And so the big underlying question
under.
All this is like, what do we.
Do? Like, how do how do we actually
like form sentences?
How do we actually make arguments?
How do we actually, like, write
screenplays and like, write poetry
and like, do all the things we do
and like.
How much of what we do is.
A trick. And so.
We'll come back to that.
In a second.
But but look, so let me let me
describe what what elements, what.
These things actually are like.
Watch out.
CBT So, so what?
So what they actually are is they're
basically very fancy autocomplete,
right? And so autocomplete is like a
standard computer function.
If you have an iPhone.
Right, whatever it happens, you
know, you start typing a word and it
will offer you an auto completion
right of the rest of that word.
So you don't take the whole word.
And then, you know, Google Gmail
has.
Autocomplete now for sentences where
you start typing a sentence, Oh, I'm
sorry, I can't make it your event.
And it will kind of it'll suggest
the rest of the sentence.
And so basically what?
What l l m xaa.
Is basically auto complete across a
paragraph or across five paragraphs.
Right? Or by the way, maybe an.
Auto complete across 20 pages or in
the future, by the way, maybe an
auto complete across an entire book.
Right? Like in other words, like you
should close your eyes and imagine a
future version of this thing.
Right. You sit down to write your
next book. This literally something
is.
Going to happen here. You'll sit
down.
To write your next book.
You'll type the first sentence, and
it will suggest the rest of the
book.
Right now, are you going to want
what it suggested?
Maybe right when we'll
come back.
To scenarios where that might be
the.
Case?
Probably not, but it's going to give
you a suggestion.
Right. And it's going to give you a
suggestion. It's going to give you a
suggested chapters.
It's going to give you a suggested
topics. It's going to use suggested
examples. It's going to get, you
know, suggested ways to word things.
You know, you're going to you can
already do this with chapter.
You can type in like, look, you
know, here's my draft.
Like, you know, here's you know,
here's five paragraphs I just wrote,
you know, how how could this.
Be worded.
Better?
How could this be worded more
simple?
How could this be worded in a way
that people who are younger.
Can understand it?
Right. And so it's going to be able
to autocomplete kind of in all
of these kind of very interesting
ways. And then it's and then it's up
to the human being who.
Steering it to decide, you know,
what to do with that.
And so this is kind of my point,
right? Is that a trigger or is that
a breakthrough? Right.
The answer is like yes to both.
Like yes, it's a trick.
In other words, well, here's a
critique. Here's a critique of.
Here's a critique of Williams.
And so there's there's this guy, Ian
McEwan, who's a legend in the field
of A.I., who's who's out at beta.
And he's been he's been.
Tweeting this publicly.
His Twitter account has gotten very
active lately.
And he's like, look, he's like,
he's our he argues this is more
trick than breakthrough.
And he argues basically it's.
Like, look, this thing autocomplete,
it's right. It's like a puppy.
It like auto completes the text It
thinks you want to see, but it
doesn't actually understand any of
the things that it's saying, Like it
doesn't actually know who people
are.
It doesn't know how physics works.
It doesn't know how math works.
Right. Like it doesn't like it.
And it has this thing that it's
called.
Hallucination.
In a field where, like, if it
doesn't have an autocomplete, it's
like factually correct.
It's like a.
Puppy. It still wants to make you
happy.
And so it will autocomplete a.
Hallucination and it'll start making
up like names and dates and
historical events that never
happened. You know.
The thing that that always sounds
like to me, I know the term is
hallucination.
The thing that it always connects
with to me is imposter syndrome.
I mean, it sounds like,
you know, I don't know whether
humans have the imposter syndrome or
the AIS do, but we're all just
saying the thing that we think
someone wants to hear.
So. So this goes to the underlying
question, which is what do people
do? Right? And this is where things
get like incredibly uncomfortable,
like for, you know, for a lot.
Of people to think about this, which
is like, okay.
Like like what is human
consciousness? Like, how do we form
ideas? Like, how do we decide?
I mean, I, I don't know
about you. What I've found in my
life is that, number
one, a lot of people in the day to
day.
Basis are just telling you what they
think you want to hear.
Right. And it's just and for a lot
of people, it's just much.
More for you than for me.
Maybe. Although, you know, look, a
lot of this just, you know, walking
down the street or working with, you
know, working with anybody in a
professional context or, you know,
working, you know, we're going the
customers, you know, take, you know,
buy, buy a buy a coat and then take
it back.
Next week and complain to the
customer service rep.
Right. The customer service.
Rep, You know, they're thinking,
wow, you.
Know, this person is a real, you.
Know, whatever.
Like but they're not saying that.
Like, they're saying.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
You know, this customer, you know,
how can I help you?
Right? So, so life is full of
these like life is full of these
auto complaints, like
kind of as is.
And they look like, you know, you
see this an intellectual debate,
like an intellectual debate.
I mean, you guys live this life
like how many people are making
arguments that they.
Actually have conceived of.
Right.
And that they actually believe it
versus how many people are making
arguments. Any intellectual debate
that are basically the arguments
that they think people are expecting
them to make.
Right. And, you know, this is where
you see this thing in politics.
Where basically it's this weird
thing in politics that you guys are
kind of an exception to this weird
thing in politics where.
Most people have the.
Exact same sets of views as
everybody else on their side on
every conceivable issue.
Right.
I mean, isn't that a coincidence?
Every time how that happens?
Every single time.
Right. And it's like, well, it's and
you know, what do we know?
We know that those people have not
sat down and thought through all.
Of those issues.
And first principle and we know
that they haven't automatically
arrived at all the same views.
We know this what's.
What's happened, of course, as a
social reinforcement mechanism.
Right. So people are saying what
they what they what they think is.
Necessary to fit into society.
So is that actually
any better than the machine
essentially trying to do the same
thing? Like, I think it's kind
of the same like. So I think what
we're going to learn is that we're a
lot more like churchy pretty
than we thought, Right.
Well, so there's another another way
to come at this, which is there's
this thing.
Called the Turing Test. Right.
So there Alan.
Turing. I mentioned he he's sort of
early on, he.
Created this this thing called the
Turing Test.
And the Turing.
Test was basically his attempt.
Basically, he said, look, if let's
suppose we develop what we think is
an AI, let's suppose we develop a
program and we think it's smart in
the same way that a person is smart.
And, you know, how will we.
Know that it's actually smarter?
So he proposed this thing called the
Turing Test. And the Turing test.
Basically you have a human subject
and then they're in a chat room and
they're in a chat room with a human
being and with the computer and
both the human being and the
computer, they're in the chat room
with or trying to convince.
Them that they're actually the real
person. That is the other one is the
computer.
Right. And then basically
and then the question is basically.
Is the computer as good as or better
than the person, right.
The other person at.
Convincing the subject that they're
actually human beings.
Right. And so the theory there
basically is the test is if a
computer can convince you that it's
a human being, that it then it
effectively.
Is like it's every bit as
intelligence, intelligent and
sentient conscious as a as a as
a.
Human.
The obvious problem with.
The Turing Test, right.
Is that we're really people are
really easy to trick, right?
We're like super easy to con, right.
And like, life is filled with like,
you know, everybody's life is filled
with people trying to con them.
Every time you watch a TV
commercial, they're trying to, you
know, can you every time you talk to
a salesperson, you know.
There's just this constant, you
know, every time you're, you know,
three card monte, you know, you
know, a magician doing a card trick
politician on TV, right?
They're always trying to con you in
some way. And we know you know, we
know that human.
Beings are, like relatively
susceptible to being conned.
And so a computer that's good at
conning you, right?
Is that actually like is that A.I.
or is that just basically revealing
an underlying weakness.
In actually what we think of as that
which is profoundly human.
Which is like we're really easy to
trick. And if we're that easy to
trick, it's like, okay.
Well, how smart are we?
Right. And so I think that you see
what I'm saying. Like, there's no
single there's no single vector of
like smart versus not smart.
It's more like, okay, there are
certain sets of things that people
can do better or worse.
There are certain sets of things
computers can do better for.
Worse, you know, better or worse.
The things computers can do that are
better are getting really good.
I mean, another way to think about
this, if you try like Mid Journey or
Dolly.
Or these new.
Art.
Generating things.
But like you know these things now,
like at their best they're
generating art that is I think
pretty clearly let's say,
you know, Esthetically Superior it's
like a very deep thing, but let's
just say more beautiful, like
they're able to produce art that is
more beautiful than.
All but maybe a handful of human
artists. Like just objectively, you
look at them, you're like, Wow,
that's beautiful.
And so, you know, two years
ago, did we expect did we expect a
computer to make to be making
beautiful art? No, we didn't.
Can it do it now routinely?
Yes.
What does that mean in terms of what
human artists do? Like, if there's
only a few human artists that can
produce.
Art that.
Beautiful, Maybe we're not that good
at making art. Maybe.
You see, I'm saying.
Yeah. So I think a lot you've
been sort of using the language of
humanity, like humans are like this.
Humans have these attributes, but
some of this at least is cultural.
And the question it raises for me is
one that I think is also kind of a
political question.
How much does it matter where
these eyes emerge?
Like, should we care if AI's
are American or
coming out of Silicon Valley versus
coming from another cultural
place?
So I think we should
sell.
Among the things we're talking about
here are.
are the future of warfare.
Right.
So, you know, what is.
You know, you can see it, the
self-driving car. Like, if you have
a self-driving car, that.
Means you can have a cell flying
plane, right?
That means you can have a
self-guided submarine.
Right. That means you can have,
like, you know, smart route.
You could have you know, you have
this concept now we see in Ukraine
with the so-called loitering
munitions.
Right.
Which is basically a suicide drone.
It's a it's a it's a it's a drone
that's a suicide bomb, basically.
Suicide being that it kills itself.
But it just like.
Stays in the sky until it sees a
target and it just like zeroes in
and, you know, drops grenade or it
itself is the bomb.
And so this whole like
the whole era, the whole era I
just watched the new Top Gun movie,
right? And like and they kind
of they allude to this a little bit
in the movie, which is it's like a
human being, you know, to train
an F-16 or F-18 fighter pilot.
Right. Is like.
You know, I don't know, seven,
eight, ten, $15 million
plus. It's it's a you know, a very
valuable human being.
And, you know, we put these people
in these tin cans and then.
We fly them through the air, you
know, whatever, mock whatever.
And then, you know, they actually do
a good job in the movie.
Of like the G force issue.
Right. Which is like, you.
Know, the plane is capable of
maneuvering in.
Ways that will actually kill the
pilot.
And so what the plane can do is
actually.
Constrained by what that what the
human body can.
Actually put up with.
And then, by the way, the the plane
that is.
Capable of sustaining human life is
like very big and expensive.
Right. And has all these systems to
be able to accommodate the human
pilot.
Look at supersonic air drone is
not going to.
Have any of those restraints.
Right. So first of all, it's going
to cost a fraction of the price.
Right? Second is it can be, you
know, much smaller, by the way, much
bigger. It doesn't need to have even
the shape.
That we associate today with it
could have any shape that's
aerodynamic.
Right. It doesn't need to take into
account, you know, human pilot.
It can fly faster, it can maneuver
faster, It can do all kinds of
turns. Right.
And, you know, acceleration, all
kinds of things that human the human
pilot's body can't tolerate.
It can make decisions much more
quickly. You know, it can generate
much more.
Information, you know, per per
second.
Than.
Any human being can.
It can make, you know, decisions
very fast. And then.
By the way, you're not just going to
have one of those.
You're going to have, you know, at a
time you're going to.
Ten or.
100 or a thousand or 10,000 or
100,000. Those things flying at the
same time.
Right. And so these things are going
to come out of the sky in swarms.
There's a there's one movie that
has.
Gotten this right. It's a it's a
movie. It's an action movie.
Gerard Butler called Angel Has
Fallen.
And in the opening scene,
there's a terror attack against the
US president in the movie, played
by, of course, Morgan Freeman.
Um, is fishing
on this big, beautiful lake and.
He's got all these Secret Service
guys around.
And.
All of a sudden there's what looks
like a flock of birds, you know, big
flock of birds coming through the
distance. And it turns out they're
suicide drones.
And the movie does a really good job
of showing like.
What that kind of attack is going to
be like.
And it's like, this is all like.
This is all under right, like this.
This is all happening.
This is all going to happen.
Like this is just very, very clear.
It's very obvious it's going to
happen very brightly.
You know, look, the the the nation
states with the best air
capabilities are going to have the
best defense capabilities that.
By the way, the duties already on
this video.
The Department of Defense in the
U.S. has already declared that air
is what they call the third offset,
which is basically it means the
future of warfare.
Right. So they're going to
completely rotate how they spend
money.
And so like this, is it like the
future? You know, if there's ever
if there's ever.
I mean, God forbid, but if there's
ever a war between the U.S.
and China, like this is the form
that it's going to take.
And so, yeah, it's going to matter.
You know, it's.
Like asking who have the atomic
bomb? Like it's going to matter a
great deal.
Do you think?
Like I think that that's the kind
of national security implications
are obviously huge.
I also wonder about it kind of from
the other direction, like
will our allies have
American values or American
personalities or something like
that? I'm sort of wondering about
like not only the effects,
but also, you know,
is there is there a cultural
component to the type of
air we're going to get?
Or is that a math
problem? And it's that, you know,
it's wrong to think about it as
having this kind of human overlay.
You know. So I think it's 100% I
think it's 100% right.
And furthermore, I guess what the
way I would think about it is, if
you look at the fight that's
happened over social media, both
in the U.S. and in China, right.
Over the last ten years, right where
both in the U.S., there's been a
massive fight over like what values
are encoded in social media and like
what, you know, censorship controls
and what, you know, ideologies are
allowed to, you know, perpetuate so
forth.
Like there's been a massive fight on
that in the U.S. And of course,
there's a constant running fight on
that in China.
Right.
Which is, you know, the Great
Firewall.
And they've got all their
restrictions
on what they allow you to to show if
you're Chinese citizen. And then
there's these cross-cultural
questions. Right. Which is this sort
of whole thing where people are
wondering, it's like, well, you
know, Tik Tok is a Chinese platform
running in the U.S.
with, you know, American users and
especially like American children,
using it.
Like, you know, is, you know, a
lot of people have theories.
At least the tick tock is the tick
tock algorithm is very deliberately
steering us kids towards destructive
behaviors.
And is that, you know, some sort of
foreign, you know, basically, you
know, operation Hostile operation.
And so anyway, like to the
extent that these are all big issues
in this previous.
Era of social media, I think all of
these issues magnify out by like a
million types in this area.
Like all of those issues become just
like far more. Dramatic and far more
important and far more profound.
And the reason is just because user
generated content is kind of we're
talking about like user generated
content on social media.
People only generate so many kinds
of content. They only engage on so
many different kinds of issues.
Whereas AI is going to be universal,
like.
A.I. is going.
To be applied to everything.
It's going to be involved in
everything. It's going to be
integral to the health care system
that's going be integral to the, you
know, just like the financial system
to education.
It's going to permeate education.
Right? And so it's going
to be relevant.
To basically every field of human
activity where anybody can have an
opinion about anything.
And that.
Yeah.
Is that what you just described?
Is that a case for
early and cautious regulation?
Is that a case for the impossibility
of regulation?
Where does that take us in terms of
what lawmakers could or should be
doing?
What would a Reason magazine say
about. Well.
You know, the reason I think.
Well, so actually, we're doing
a debate issue coming up.
And we have we
have a debate on regulation of AI.
And there are people who are, of
course, deeply skeptical
of governments who still say,
well, maybe there maybe this is
the moment for guardrails.
You know, maybe at least we want to
say we want to limit how states
can use AI, for instance,
even if we don't want to limit
individuals.
I mean, I'll make your own argument
back to you, which I know you'll
enjoy, Right? Which is like, you
know, road to hell.
Right. The road to hell is paved
with good intentions, you know?
You know, everybody always wants.
It's like, boy, wouldn't it be great
this time, right?
If we could have, like, very
carefully calibrated well thought
through, like, rational, reasonable,
right, Like, effective, like
regulation, like, wouldn't that be
great?
Like, you know, maybe this time we
can make rent control work, right?
If we just let you know, if we.
Just, like, if we just if we're a
little bit smarter.
About it. I mean, you know, your
argument, you know, you're an
argument.
Obviously is like, well, no, that's
not actually what you know, that's.
You know, that's not.
Actually what happens. Right.
For all the reasons you guys talk
about all the time.
So, yeah, I mean, look, there's an
abstract theoretical argument for
such a thing. We don't get the
abstract theoretical regulation.
We get the practical real world
regulation, you.
Know, And what don't we get out the
other.
Side, right? We get regulatory
capture.
You know, we get we get, you know,
we get we get corruption.
You know, we get we get basically
incumbent your early incumbent, lock
em.
You know, we.
Get we get basically political
capture.
You know, I mean, we get we get out,
we get.
All this you know, we get we get
basically skewed, skewed incentives.
And then, you know, years later,
we're wonder like, how could we've
done that to ourselves? And it's
because everybody in that moment
said, wow, we really need some sort
of well-intentioned regulation that
we can't actually get.
So, I mean, you know, look, God
bless, you know, I don't know.
They'll probably try to get, you
know, and then this is the other
thing is like, you know, is it is it
good or bad that our.
Government is largely dysfunctional
and, you know, generally speaking,
can't pass legislation.
Here? You know, the.
Libertarian in me says, you know,
this is this is a case where
gridlock is good.
You know, look, the straight power
politics version of this is like we
can't even ban tick tock, Right.
Like, you know, American social.
Media companies aren't allowed to
operate in China.
The Chinese company.
Is allowed to operate in the U.S.
with total impunity.
You know, you do look at the content
on tick tock.
It's going to kids in the U.S.
and you do wonder, like, what's
going on? And there have been
repeated attempts to block, you
know, tick tock of U.S.
and they've all you know, it's
still, you know, tick tock, still
running in the U.S. just fine.
So I don't know, it's like we can't
even ban tick tock.
You know, we you know, we couldn't
you know, we couldn't effectively.
Regulate the too big to fail banks.
You know, we you know,
I'm calling me skeptical,
but, you know, yeah.
I'm sure they'll try.
You've talked a lot. You're on
record talking about the quite
rapid process through which
innovative tech startups become
kind of grumpy, enmeshed incumbents,
both just with the state and more
generally in their business
practices.
And that topic has come up
a lot recently with the Twitter
files and the sort of
revelations of the ways
that companies
collaborated with willingly,
I think in many cases, but maybe
with a looming threat as well
with government agencies around this
information and other questions.
And it seems to me
like we're going to be in for more
of that, that this sort
of blurring of the lines between
public and private is our fate.
Is that what it looks like to you?
And if so, you know,
is that ultimately a thing that
threatens innovation or
are there ways in which it could
potentially speed things along?
Yeah, So, you know, look, the
textbook view of the American
economy is that it's you know, it's
a it's a free market competition.
And, you know, companies are
fighting it out. And, you know,
different toothpaste companies are
trying to sell you a different
toothpaste.
And it's a largely competitive
market. And then every once in a
while, there's an extra analogy that
requires government intervention.
And then you get, you know, these
weird things like, you know, the too
big to fail banks or whatever.
But, you know, those are the
exceptions to the general working of
the free market system.
You know, look, I can tell you my
experience having been now in
startups for 30 years is that the
opposite is true.
Specifically that James Burnham was
right.
That we passed from the original
model of capitalism, which he called
bourgeois capitalism, which is what
we still think capitalism is.
We passed into a different model,
which he called managerial
capitalism, you know, some
some decades back.
And the the the actual.
Correct. Model of how the US economy
works is it is mostly
a process of oligopolies, cartels
and monopolies.
And they mostly it's mostly
them.
You know, for it's basically big
companies forming up in oligopolies,
cartels and monopolies and doing
all of the things that you expect
oligopolies, cartels, monopolies to
do.
And then they jointly.
Basically corrupt and capture the
regulatory and government process.
And so they end up controlling the
regulators.
And so most.
Sectors of the economy are a
conspiracy between the big
incumbents and their putative
regulators.
And the purpose of the.
Conspiracy is to perpetuate the
long term existence of those
monopolies and cartels.
And to.
Block new competition.
Like so.
So that's why that's where I've come
out on.
To me, that completely explains
the education system, both
K-through-12.
And the college university system.
It completely explains the health
care system.
It completely explains the housing
crisis.
It completely explains.
2008, the financial crisis and the
bailouts.
It completely explains the Twitter
files. Like, I think that's
precisely what what.
Has been happening in tech.
And so if you're if you're if you're
if you're if you're open to that
interpretation of.
How the world works and how the
country works and how the economy
works.
Then like a lot of.
Things start to make a tremendous
amount of sense.
And then, you know, I think what
the.
Twitter file says is it's basically
an X-ray of of a specific instance
of that happening.
Which is just factual.
What we now know from the.
Twitter files is that a very large
number of people in government.
By the way, some of them political
and, you know, some of them like
politicians, but also some of them
bureaucrats. Right.
And so some of the members of.
The right deep state.
Right. Which either, you know, as we
know, the deep state either does not
exist or if it does exist, it's
good.
Right? One of the other I
think that's.
What I've heard.
Yeah, that's what I've heard is that
recent.
Book on that apparently makes that
case very, very clearly.
So let's just say like the permanent
bureaucracy or again, what James
Burnham would tell you is like the.
Managerial class in government,
right? The sort of permanent cadre
of professionals in government who
basically manage everything.
And, you know, those people
and then also people on the outside
who they fund as their proxies.
Right.
With government money, with taxpayer
money. Right.
Have been exerting enormous
pressure.
On Twitter to block
censor.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
You know, and you know what looks
to.
Me like a straightforward
constitutional
case for a deprivation of
constitutional rights.
You know, the first, Fourth and
Fifth Amendments.
In a way that is clearly illegal
both under the Constitution and
under.
As its title 18,
whatever, to 42.
You know, there's a specific federal
law that says it's a felony.
It's a felony for a government
official to use the power of being
in government to deny citizens
of constitutional rights.
There's actually, by the way,
another law. There's 241 that.
Actually applies that same principle
to private citizens, including
private companies.
And so I think it's possible that
there has actually I think it's
possible that there's actually been
criminal activity both on the
government side and on the company
side.
And yeah, and it's just like, yeah,
that's been happening. And you know,
the Twitter for every new drop of
the Twitter.
Files shows that that's what's
what's been happening.
You know, in a, in a, in
a nonpolitical world where.
We all just like read the
Constitution, you know, this would
be a constitutional crisis.
You know, this would be the biggest
story in the country.
There would be hearings.
You know, there would be, you know,
among other, you know, immediate
impeachment proceedings, like, you
know, this this would be a five
alarm fire.
Right. Because obviously, the
government can't be allowed to do
this.
You know, in our in our in our
in the real world, of course.
That's not what's happening.
And, you know.
And we're back.
To either either denial or.
Embrace under the theory that this
is good and proper.
Right.
Are there sectors that are less
subject to that dynamic
that you just described in which the
start up quickly become the
incumbents enmeshed with the state?
I mean, look, so I think it's so
my my theory basically is if the
question is always the same question
like is there actual competition?
Right. Like so so so actually
I think there's like a deeper my my
deeper idea here is it's basically
the process of evolution.
So the idea of capitalism.
Is basically an economic form of the
idea of evolution, right?
And natural selection and the
survival of the fittest and the idea
that basically it's a superior
product ought to win in the market
and that markets ought to ought to
be open to competition and a better,
you know, a new company can come
along with a better widget and take
out the incumbents because its
widget is superior and customers
like it better.
And so like for evolution to
proper.
To function properly, you need
survival of the fittest, which means
you need things to die when they're
not the best thing for capitalism
to work properly, you need.
The same thing to happen.
You need companies to die when they
are inferior.
To other companies that are doing
things better.
Right? That that, you know, that's
that's sort of inherent to that.
To the thing. And so the question.
Always is like, is there actual
competition happening or not?
Right. Is and, you know, in part
it's like, do consumers actually
have the ability to.
Freely select among the existing
alternatives? And then the other
question is, can new can new
products actually come to market?
Right. You know, can.
You can you actually bring.
A new widget to market or do you get
blocked out? Because the regulatory
wall that's been established is, you
know, basically makes it prohibitive.
I mean, look, the great.
Example of this is is banking.
Right, where, you know, the big
thing in 2008 was we need to.
Bail out these banks because
they're, quote unquote, too big to
fail. And so then there were screams
of the need to reform the too big to
fail banks that led to.
Frank, the results of Dodd Frank.
I call it the Big Bank.
Protection Act of 2011.
Right.
The result of that is that the too
big to fail banks are now much
larger than before.
And the number of new banks.
Being created in the U.S.
has dropped to zero.
Right, Because it's now effectively
impossible.
To launch a new bank in the U.S.
because, you know, Jp morgan Chase
has 10,000 lawyers working
on their regulatory issues.
And you have one.
Like it's it's not.
Possible, like you can't start new
banks anymore.
And so anyway, sorry.
So I'm repeating the I'm repeating
the case against.
So but the question is like, where
is that not happening?
Like, you know, where where in the
where in the market is that actually
not happening?
You know.
Where is there free and open
competition?
You know, look, the cynical answer
is this. It's not that doesn't.
Happen in the spaces that don't
matter. Right?
Like so toys like
anybody can bring a new toy to
market. Like, it's fine.
Sure. Great. Right.
Anybody can you know, I don't know.
Like, anybody can open a restaurant,
right? I mean, just say don't
matter. Being like, you know, these
are fine and good like.
You know, consumer categories that
people really enjoy and so forth.
But as contrasted to the.
Health care system or the education
system. Right. Or the housing
system.
Right or the legal system.
Your business better.
If you want freedom, your business
better be frivolous.
I mean.
That would be that would be the
cynical way of looking at it.
Like if if it doesn't matter from a
societal structure.
Right. In terms of like determining
the power structure of society and.
Basically the power of the
government in society.
Then yeah, go crazy, do whatever you
want. But like if it actually
matters.
To like major issues of policy,
right, where the government is
intertwined with them, then of
course it doesn't happen there.
And again, it doesn't happen.
There, not just because of the
government,
it doesn't happen there because of
the intertwining of the incumbents
and the government.
You know, look, I think this stuff
is good. Look, this is one of these
things where I almost have trouble
debating. I'm not debating it with
you, but like, debating it with
people who argue with me on this,
because I think it's so self-evident.
It's like, well, why aren't there?
You know, it's like, why are all
these.
Universities, like, identical?
Like, why are all of the major.
Universities implementing the exact
same, like, crazy.
Like. Why do they all have, like,
identical ideologies, Right?
Why isn't there, like a why isn't
there a marketplace of ideas.
That you at the university level.
Right. And it's like, well, that
becomes a question of like, why
aren't there more universities?
Okay, well, I can tell you why there
aren't more universities. There are
more.
Universities because to be a new
university, you have to get
accredited.
The accreditation Bureau
is.
Is run by the existing universities.
Like it.
It's sitting there in plain sight.
I'll give you the other another
example. Why do health care prices
do what they do? Right.
Why? Why? Why do health care prices
work the way.
That they work? A major reason for
that.
Is because they because
basically they're paid for by
insurance.
There's private insurance.
And public insurance that private
insurance prices just kick off the
public prices because Medicare
basically drives the whole thing,
because Medicare is the big buyer.
So how a medicare price is set,
they're set by a unit inside.
HHS called CMS.
And and CMS
runs literal.
Soviet style price fixing boards
for.
Medical goods and services.
And so once a year.
There are doctors who get together
in a conference room at like a Hyatt
Chicago somewhere.
And they sit down and they establish
they fix they do the exact same
thing that what was that unit of.
The Communist Party in in
in Russia that used to do this in
the Soviet.
Union?
There's a term for it. There was the
central price fixing bureau.
Right. So the Soviets had a central
price fixing bureau.
It didn't work.
We don't have that for the entire
economy, but we have that for the
entire health care system.
Right. And it doesn't work for the
same reason that the Soviet system
didn't work. Right.
And so we've exactly replicated.
The Soviet system expecting better
results.
It operates in plain sight.
You can go on the CMS.
CMS has a website.
I'll explain this all to you.
It's operating in plain sight.
Everybody thinks it's a great idea.
And then, you know.
Lots of people are calling for
increased government, you know,
centralized control in purchasing
health care, which would make that
system stronger.
And so it's like we we know that
this is not going to work.
We know that's going to only.
Result in restrictions on supply and
rising prices.
We know precisely what the outcome.
Is going to be.
We seem perfectly happy with it and
then we complain about it.
So.
Yeah, yeah.
I want to pivot a little bit and ask
sort of in this vein of, you know,
everyone is trying to build a system
that does good and they seem to
want the government to do it all the
time, but a little bit differently.
What has made money for
you or for your investors that you
think has also done the most
to make the world a better place?
Oh, I mean, it's even hard
to. I mean, we all we all have and
we all have a narrative on that.
Yeah.
One pick your favorite among your
all your children.
My narrative is spectacular.
So, I mean, look, basically
material progress only ever.
Happens through.
Technology. There's basically only
two ways to.
Make material progress on planet
Earth.
There's only two reasons why.
We're not all living in mud huts
right now, subsistence farming all
day, which is what we used to do,
right, which is what our predecessors
did. And there's only two reasons.
One is national resource extraction,
right? And then the other is
technology.
And those are the only two those are
the only two levers on the world.
Right? Those are the only two ways
to raise standard. Standard of
living is they're the only
possibilities.
And so and, you know, natural.
Resource extraction is good up to a
point. But at some point, you know,
at some point you need to do
something
with the resources. And so that that
immediately also becomes an
application of technology.
And so, you know, on the materialist
side, right, which is the.
Obvious more obvious one, which is
your standard of living, you know,
standard of living in the U.S.
is up like eight bucks in the last,
you know, whatever it is, 75 years
or some crazy number like that.
Like it is true, you know,
the engine of technology routinely.
Is producing, you know, enhancements
to standard of.
Living. And of course, they're.
The thought experiment is very easy,
which is.
You know, you know, notwithstanding
whatever.
Problems people have with, you know,
current modernity or postmodernity.
Or whatever we're living in, like,
would you switch places.
With your predecessor 50 years ago,
you know, from from a material
well-being standpoint?
And.
You know.
You answer that for basically
everybody else is no.
And of course, we also know that
because, you know, you could build
cities and towns.
Today if you wanted to, where people
voluntarily, you know, didn't use
technology made after 1950 or
something.
And, you know, the Amish.
Do that. But like, you know, nobody
else does it.
And so, you know, material standards
of living are.
You know, continue to advance.
I think that that and I think that's
a perfectly fine a good argument.
And then.
I and then look, I also think the
other side from.
In terms of my my philosophy,
there's like a human freedom right
and flourishing aspect to it, like
the, you know, the sort of
intellectual or maybe even the
spiritual side.
And, you know, there it's just like,
okay, like are people more free.
To, like, learn and explore
and express themselves and be
themselves and find like.
Minded people, right?
And discover their.
Calling in life.
Right.
And, you know.
If they're creating something, bring
their creation to market.
And find the audience for it
or the market for it.
Like, you know, all of the like
the.
Ability of sort of humans to
self-actualize.
Like is that expanding over time or.
Diminishing over time?
And and I think like overwhelmingly.
The impact of the Internet has been
to expand that.
Now there is this, you know, giant
world.
It's happening where there's lots of
people who are trying to like shut
that, you know, shut aspects of that
down and control that.
But nevertheless, I think I think
everybody was going to have to
concede.
Like the Internet has made it much.
More possible for a much broader
range of voices, a much broader
range of ideas.
I mean, you know, I read and see
things on.
The Internet.
Today that like, you know.
25 years.
Ago, you know, you would have.
In a car, you know.
You would you would have had to go.
Deep into the car catalog at some,
you know, giant university campus.
If you could have gotten access to
it to find some book that was
written in like 1820 or something.
You know, And today.
It's just like tap, tap, tap, Google
search. Oh, I can you know, I can
find you know, I can find out all
about this. And then I and then I
can write about it myself.
And so, yeah, you know, people
people, people.
Actually do have like a much greater
level of, let's say, personal
freedom.
Yeah. Look, having said that, like
the war to try to control that.
And took that off is also very real.
What do you think is a better use
of time and
resources trying to
start a company or
giving away money to a or the
worthiest cause?
Oh, I mean, I think overwhelmingly
the former it's
overwhelming to the former.
So and this is and this is an
argument, right, that very, very few
people in our modern, you.
Know, kind of society, modern.
You know, whatever civil religion
are willing to make. But, you know,
I'll.
Make it, which is.
Production is a good of itself,
right? Like, you know, the person
who makes your.
Toothpaste is doing, you know, the
company that makes your toothpaste
is doing something for you.
Right. That is superior to that of,
you know, most people doing health
philanthropy. Right, like.
Production of the goods and
services.
That make our lives better.
Right. And at the limit, you know,
the goods and.
Services that like cure diseases and
so forth.
You know.
They're generally for profit
companies. The fact that they make
money on those things is just reward
for having improved the world.
You know, I think most most of the
actual.
Like material progress in the world,
most of the most of the improvement
in human welfare is done through
through for profit production.
So so. So I've I've
you know, I'm you know, there are
people who are like basically
capitalism. You know, building a
company is a necessary evil to
generate the money with.
Which we can then make the world
better. I'm like, No, that's not the
case.
Like, most of the good you're going
to do in the.
World is going to be through building
your company, and then maybe you're
going to find a way to do some
philanthropy thing.
You know, hopefully the philanthropy
thing that you do is not going to
make the world worse, not better,
which is often an interesting
question.
Here's the other reason I believe
that so strongly, which is
and again, this let's assume some
sort of properly.
Functioning capitalism, right, with
some level of effective competition
in the market.
You know, production in the for
profit system, like the products
succeed or fail, they're adopted or
they're not adopted.
On the basis of whether people want
them. Right. And whether people
think that they make their lives
better and people want to engage in
that trade.
And so there's like there's like a
there's a there's a direct.
Reality test with every transaction,
right. As to whether this is
actually something that people want
and whether this is something that
people think will improve their
lives.
You know, there is this massive
issue with.
Philanthropy, which has always been
an issue, and it continues to be an
issue, which is it's just it's not
subject to market test.
And so, you know, there are, you
know.
Reams and reams and reams of
examples and studies of
philanthropic programs that, you
know, thought that they were going
to, you know, lead to some
sort of beneficial outcome in some
area.
And then it.
Turned out they backfire horribly.
Right. And, you know, there's an
obvious.
One just kind of staring us all in
our face today, which is, you know,
criminal justice reform.
Right. You know, there's been this
wave of philanthropists, many.
Of whom I.
Know over the course of the last 20
years who have, you know, spent an
enormous amount of money putting in
place a new set of politicians and a
new set of political ideas that
have resulted in letting the
criminals out of jail.
And as a, you know, for justice.
And as a consequence, like crime is
through the roof and it's like not
safe to be on the streets.
And it's just like but like
there's no market test, like the
people who have spent all of that
money. Right.
To let all the criminals out.
Like they're not subject to the risk
of all the criminals being out
because they.
All have like Navy SEAL teams
protecting them.
Right?
Because they're all like, rich.
Right. And so they're able
to just like, arbitrarily, like,
ruin society.
You know, through philanthropic
efforts with no corrective mechanism
whatsoever.
And so, you know, if anything,
the world we're in today, like the
dichotomy between, like the actual
good.
At production.
And then the actual evil of.
Sort of the unintended consequences
of sort of untested, quote unquote
philanthropy, like, I think those.
Are gapping.
Out in a pretty profound way.
Again, it's hard for me to even talk
about this the.
Most people because I just I think
it's kind of obvious. It's like walk
down the street in San Francisco,
it's pretty obvious what's
happening.
And yet, like the level.
Of denial among a lot of people I
talked to about this is like through
the roof.
So there's also
the kind of.
I mean, there's something that shows
up in the kind of effective altruist
critique, right, where you say,
well, you know, why?
Why give to the opera when people
are dying of malaria?
Right. That's sort of the previous
effective outros critique, I guess.
What do you give to, if anything?
Well, by the way, that the malaria
thing, this goes to the nature of
the problem, right? The nature of
the philanthropy problem, the.
Nature of the effective altruism
problem, which is. Right. Okay, fair
enough. Like, don't get to the opera
because people are dying.
And Blair notes, okay, what do we do
to keep people from dying from
malaria?
Well, we give the bednets, right?
And the bed.
Nets are like treated with chemicals
that, you know, prevent the
mosquitoes from from being able to,
you know, to be able to, you know,
to to spread malaria.
But now we've given people, you
know, nets that are treated with
chemicals, and then they turn around
and they use those nets to go
fishing. But they use that, you
know, and then the chemical
treatment on the nets ruins, ruins
the fishing environment. Right.
Like and now people start.
Right. And it's like, by the way,
maybe that happens and maybe it
doesn't, but like, it's happening
8000 miles away,
right? In a way that you're never
going to even know, like what's
happening. And so these, like,
cosmic, big brained utilitarian.
Ideas that people are going to like
have an Excel spreadsheet where
they're going to figure this stuff
out, or they're going to sit on the
campus at Stanford or Oxford or
something and have these ideas that
it's going to translate into the
real world.
I mean, my favorite example.
I'm sure you're familiar with this,
but my favorite example I keep
trying to get all my friends to
read.
Is the.
Moynihan.
Report.
From 1965.
So. Right. Daniel Patrick Moynihan
wrote this report.
About.
The rate of single
parenthood in the US in 1965.
And he sort of a lot of social
scientists will tell you like a huge
number of like life outcomes, at the
very least correlate to whether you
grew up in a double parent or single
parent home.
And so the Moynihan area, Moynihan
was like the leading light of like
the.
Liberal progressive reform movement
in 1965 with LBJ, with the Great
Society, and you had the full
resources of the government, you
know, like unlimited capability
consultation with experts.
And he wrote this report and it was
like we have this huge crisis
because of the percentage of unwed
births.
And then as a consequence, we're
going to implement all of these
incredible programs, both government
programs and philanthropic programs,
you know, to fix this.
And then fast forward, you know,
sitting here today, 50 years later.
You know.
The percentage of unwed versus
tripled.
Right. Right.
By him or by the way, with no
accounting. Right. Like with no
accounting, no accountability.
He's dead.
He doesn't have to live with the
consequences.
Nobody's looking at this.
Nobody cares.
You know, maybe you guys write a
story on it or, you know, somebody
does it, but, like, nobody cares,
like, and those programs.
Continue on autopilot forever.
And so I just, you know, I
just find it's like this remote
control.
Aspect to it. It's just, like,
incredibly disturbing.
It does.
And again, I go back to this is the
thing. Like any business, any for
profit business cannot any
legitimate for.
Profit business that operates in a
true competitive market cannot do
this.
The market will prevent them from
doing this because if they do this,
the market will stop.
The market will say, No.
I do not want you to do this
anymore.
I will not buy this thing anymore.
Right. And you will go away.
Right? And there and there's there
is no.
Equivalent pressure whatsoever on a
on a foundation or philanthropist.
So.
So anyway, what do we do?
So specifically, what we do is we
basically stick very, very, very
close to home.
And specifically what we do is
basically local social.
Infrastructure and in particular we
do emergency medicine.
And so we do and.
Specifically at at Stanford.
So, you know, we basically fund
Stanford Emergency medicine, the
whole program there.
And, you know, basically under under
a couple of theories. Number one is,
you know, whatever you feel about
our health care system, it is true
that at three in the morning, you
know.
When your kid has a fever of 105 or,
you know, somebody, you know, has a
serious problem.
You know, everybody's kind of equal
at the E.R..
At three in.
The morning.
And so, you know, it.
Is the ultimate backstop for, you
know, for medical care for
everybody.
And then the other is, like any
given day, I can go sit in the
E.R. and I can see the patients.
Right. And I can see the outcomes.
Right. And I don't have to wonder
whether like.
This is a good idea or a bad idea.
Like, I can see the benefit.
There's no remote control aspect to
it at all. It's like it's like right
there, you know, it's like 10
minutes in my house.
And so, you know, that's the kind.
Of thing we do and at least try to
live up to the spirit of.
Let's say, trying to make the world
a better.
Place, but also trying to do it in a
way where we can actually prove that
we're actually doing that.
You know, you said, I think about
ten years ago now that
Bitcoin is as important
as the Internet was,
and we've had a little time for that
to play out.
It's been tumultuous.
But I guess on the theme of
this time, it's different.
How is that prediction looking to
you? You've done pretty well
financially with your investments in
that space, but not everyone
has.
Yeah, well, so there's a bunch of
things. So there's a bunch of things
in there. So.
So just the thesis of what I wrote
then, which I still believe.
So I wrote this piece as a.
New York Times.
Column. It was a New York Times
column back when.
The New York Times would run things
that I write, which, by the way.
In case you're wondering, is no
longer true.
But they ran it at the time.
And so everything
in there I still agree with.
The one modification I would make is
I at the time it looked like Bitcoin
was going to evolve and Bitcoin.
Itself was going to evolve in a way
where it was going to be used for
many other things.
We at the time.
Thought it was a general technology
platform that was going to evolve,
to be to be able to make a lot of
other applications possible in the
same way that the Internet did, in
the same way the iPhone did and so
forth.
It actually turned out they didn't
that didn't happen.
But Bitcoin itself just basically
stalled out.
It basically stopped evolving.
But what happened was about a bunch
of.
Other projects emerged and sort of
took that place. And, you know, the
big one right now is this area is
sort of there's sort of the next
derivation. And so if I wrote that
thing today, I would either say it's
Ethereum, a sort of Bitcoin, or I
would just say crypto, you know, or
Web three instead of Bitcoin.
But but otherwise.
It's all the same ideas.
All the same ideas apply.
You know, like the argument I made
in that piece that I 100% believe
today is basically
and I mean use the terms kind of
interchangeably like crypto web3
blockchain.
Use those terms kind of
interchangeably.
They're the other what I.
Call the other half of the Internet.
The Internet.
They're the other.
The other has all the functions of
the Internet that we knew that we
wanted.
To have when we originally built the
Internet as people know it today and
the web as people know it.
Today. But it's all of that.
It's all the aspects of basically
being able to like, do business and
be able to have.
Money and be.
Able to do transactions and have
trust.
Like we did not know how to use.
The Internet to do that in the
nineties. And now with this
technological breakthrough of the
blockchain, we now know how to do
that. We have we have the
technological
foundation to be able to do that.
And so and the that there is.
Basically as follows, which is
basically have a have a
have a network of trust, a digital
trust that is overlaid on top
of Internet, which is an Internet
untrusted network.
Anybody can pretend to be anybody
they want the Internet, anybody can
look up the Internet, do whatever
they want, but it's famously
untrusted.
Crypto Web three.
It creates layers of trust on top of
that. And then within those layers
of trust, you can represent money,
but you can also.
Represent many other things.
You can represent claims of
ownership that you can so you can
represent everything from house
titles, car titles, you know,
assurance contracts, loans.
You can represent claims to digital
assets. You can have things like
unique digital art,
You can have, you know, all
you can have a general concept of
like an Internet contract.
You can actually strike contracts
with people online, you know,
that they're actually held to.
You know, just an example.
You can have like Internet escrow
services like so for e-commerce, you
can have a service, you have a two
people buying from each other.
You can have actually a trusted
intermediary. Now that is Internet
native that has an escrow service.
So so it's like basically it's
like you can build on top of the
untrusted Internet, all of.
The capabilities that you would need
to have a full economy.
Right. And sort of the broadest
definition of that you other words,
like a full global Internet native
economy.
And, you know, that's a giant.
I mean, that's a giant idea.
You know, the potential there is is
is extraordinarily high.
And so, yeah, we're you know, we're
midway through that process.
We have, you know, funded and
there's lots of others.
But like there's tons of really
smart entrepreneurs who are
basically going after every aspect
of what I just described.
You know, a lot of those things have
worked. You know, some of those
things haven't worked yet.
But I think that they're going to
work.
You know, like having said that,
these things are you know, every
new thing we do is by definition
and, you know, it's.
Called venture capital for a reason.
Like these are ventures.
You know, you can.
Add the prefix add, these are
adventures.
You know, these are.
You know.
The question people always ask us.
It's like, are you are you
speculating? And I'm always like,
well, you know, it's like, I.
Don't even know what speculating is.
Like. Am I investing in something
without knowing how it's going to
go? Yes.
Is that speculation?
Yes. Is that every.
Investment? Yes.
Like yes.
You know, we're investing in a
future unknown state.
Like, you know, sometimes these
things work, sometimes they don't.
Sometimes the prices go up,
sometimes the prices go down.
We never make price predictions.
You know, we never predict that
Bitcoin price or whatever is going
to be X or Y or Z at any given
point. I have good friends of mine
who still haven't gotten the message
on this and they still call me up
and they're like, Mark, what's
bitcoin
price going to be next month?
I'm like, I don't.
It beats me, man.
You know, go look.
At the chicken entrails.
Like, I don't you know, I don't know
what to tell you.
So the prices are going to whip, you
know, the prices whip around, you
know.
Through the process of the market
trying to establish value.
Crypto looks more volatile than a
lot of other.
Categories, just because the assets
sort of list publicly in advance
of.
You know, when we back a private
company, it usually.
Doesn't go public for if it goes
public, it'll go public like seven
or eight or ten years later.
Crypto project crypto.
Tokens start to float much earlier
than that. So it's almost as if
startup equity was being traded in
the public market from the very
beginning.
You know, of course those prices
would be highly volatile.
Right? Like a critique of venture
capital is that we.
Present to our investors people
accuse us of. Sending to our
investors what looks like
artificially suppressed
volatility because the prices
of the things that we invest.
In, like in actuality.
If they were trading on the public
market, they'd be whipping all over
the place.
But we just hold them privately.
We mark them once a quarter.
We don't even know what they're
worth. Then we just let the
accountants like make some gas.
So whereas these crypto assets just
they trade.
Publicly, so.
So, so they look more volatile, I
actually don't think they're more
volatile than the other stuff that
we do.
I think that this is just all this
is just the nature of doing things
out into a speculative.
We never recommend people invest in
anything like it.
People want invest in crypto assets.
They should, but they should
understand that the level of
volatility is going to be very high.
And I think the same thing would be
true of anything, quite honestly,
that they invest in.
I want to talk about the kids these
days since you mentioned unwed
pregnancies.
And you know,
those numbers certainly like teen
pregnancy numbers recently are
down quite a bit.
Some people take that
as evidence that maybe
the kids are not all right there
on their phones all the time and
they're not having human interactions
or something. And so it's bad news
that the kids aren't having sex and
doing drugs.
What how
are the kids these days?
Are the kids all right?
You know, you sort of mentioned
earlier, education is one of those
sectors that is very, very locked
down, very, very limited
in terms of innovation.
Hard to break into.
So how are the kids doing?
And if not, well, what
can be done?
Well, some of the kids are pretty
messed up. Like,
I don't know if you've been noticing,
but some of the kids.
Seem to have some issues.
So I will I'll concede up front,
like there does.
Seem to be some problems.
So let's see a whole bunch of things
in there.
So, yeah, so. So first off, I'll say
like just the enormous irony.
I feel like there's enormous irony.
So when I was a kid, so I was a kid.
In the eighties, and when I was a
kid, it was this.
Constant.
Like moral panic, constant
media pressure of like the kids were
like, totally out of control.
Right. And it was it was literally
like the kids are all on drugs and
the kids.
Are all having, like, casual sex.
And like, the kids are basically
spiraling into nihilism and,
you know, and sort of
self-destruction.
And so I well, I can see there is a
lot of irony to be.
Sitting here today. And now there's
this other critique from the same at
least the same kind of person
basically saying, oh, the kids
aren't doing enough drugs and having
enough sex. And I'm like, okay,
well.
What do you want? What do you want?
You told us to stop doing those
things, and we did. Okay.
So, yeah, so look,
you know, there's there's deeper,
deeper questions underneath that.
You know, look at the birth rate
question. I mean, I'm sure you know
this, but like the birth rate thing
and the birth rates are crashing all
over.
The world, right?
So the most interesting thing about.
The birth rate phenomenon.
And by the way, I.
Think it's great that Ellen, you
know, it's been talking about this in
public and really elevating this
because it's a really big it's a
really big question.
But like, birthrates are crashing in
the U.S..
Birthrates are also crashing in
Europe.
And they're also crashing in Japan
and.
They're also crashing in Korea.
And they're also now crashing in
China.
And they're crashing and they're
crashing in around.
Right. And so like, whatever
is happening is not happening
because of, quote unquote.
You know, whatever American, you
know, this, that or the other thing
or even Western.
You know, or at least not like, you.
Know, just kind of facially like
whatever is unique or special or
different about Western culture like
it is. This is a broad based
phenomenon.
You know, I you know, I'm not an
expert in the thing you know, the
sort of best analysis I've.
Read seem to indicate that it's more
or less a natural consequence of,
you know, much.
Much kind of a combination of like
much.
Longer periods of education, sort of
coupled with much higher levels of
female engagement, both in the
education system and in the
workforce.
And if you sort of fully empower
everybody, both.
Men and women.
To kind of fully self-actualize
in the form.
Of basically unlimited.
Amounts of education coupled by
unlimited professional opportunities.
You basically it's like what I was
saying earlier, it's like you just
make.
Life more interesting for people.
In a way where, you.
Know, they're perfectly happy
running through their twenties and
thirties, you know, without the
obligations that come with having
children. And then of course, by the
time they decide they want to have
children, you know, if they're in
their mid-to-late thirties, it might
already be too late.
So I just go through that to
say, like, I don't even know, is
that good or bad? I don't know.
Is it Western or Eastern?
It seems to be both.
I mean, the China one is
fascinating. Like, you know, the
numbers just came out, the birth.
Rate and China's crashing even
faster than expected.
You know, it looks like they may
already have.
Passed their demographic peak.
Right where we're from, from here.
On out, the Chinese population may
only.
Age.
Right. And by the way, if you think
we have a you know, it's a people to
people who think.
We have a problem with the birth
rate like Chinese have it, the
Chinese have a real problem.
Because like, you know, it's one
thing or you contrast like.
Japan and China, right?
Like Japan has a lot of old people,
but it's extraordinarily.
Wealthy society because
of all the economic development
developments that happened between
like 1950 and and the present
like into basically a society
as economically advanced as ours or
maybe even more so.
You know, China is not that.
China's still in the middle income
zone, you know, sort of 5000 per
capita GDP or something like that.
There's no economics on earth that
can explain how they're going to
take care of all their old people,
you know, in the time frame that
they have to get ready for that.
So, yeah, this seems to be like a
big issue.
I mean, look, are we going to
reverse any of this?
Like, are we going to, you know, go
back to a model where people, you
know.
Don't have all these years of
education?
You know, by the way, maybe we
should.
We're probably not going to.
Are we going to, you know, deprive
women of the.
Professional opportunities they
have, you know, to go back to an era
where they don't have those
opportunities?
Probably not.
Are we going to you
know.
What else are we going to become
less, you know, sort of socially
progressive.
And.
You know, elevate motherhood more as
sort of a social good?
You know, probably not.
That doesn't seem to be in the
cards.
Um, you
know, another possibility here is
are we going.
To have scientific breakthroughs?
Right? So, you know, this everything
we've talked about up.
Until now is sort of assumed that
sort of the natural progression of
human birth and reproduction the old
fashioned way.
You know, look, are we going to
have, you know, cloning of embryos?
Are we going to have.
You know, external gestation
machines?
You know, are we going to be able
to.
We're going to have embryos created
from stem cells.
Right.
Such that, you know, you can you
know.
You could decide on your 60th time
to have a new baby and you could
have it. You have to have the embryo
cloned off your stem cells and then
have it, you know, have a baby
raised in a gestation tank for nine
months and out comes the other end
comes a baby.
It's like maybe
is that you know, are those
technologies being developed now?
Yes.
Are they going to freak people out?
Definitely.
I guess.
Are they necessary for the
perpetuation of the species?
Quite possibly.
Yeah. So this this is kind of my
temptation always is to say
we are going to technologically
innovate our way out of our
sociocultural problems and.
It obviously doesn't always work
like that. But I mean, you've said
the future relies on
19 year olds and the start
ups that no one's ever heard of yet.
And those 19 year olds
are going to have to come from
somewhere.
Right?
Maybe we don't need to go all the
way to like growing them,
you know, growing them in a VAT from
stem cells. But
it might help if what we need is
kind of peak weird 19 year old
to get through this right now.
Yeah, look, there's that question.
And then look, there's another giant
question that's coming up right
behind that, which is, you know, the
sort of the big genetic engineering
question.
Right. And so, like, for example,
like this is not on the horizon
right now, but like there is very,
very, you know.
Cutting edge work happening in the
genomics field to identify
all the genes that are associated
with intelligence.
Right. And there say it's already
we're up to like it's like we
already are up to like 200 genes
that correlate to like half of IQ.
And so, you know, let's
let's assume we're moving into a
world in which we're.
Increasingly going to be engineering
babies, which I think is a real
possibility for the reasons we just
discussed.
Are we also going to be optimizing
them? Right. Like, are we going to
be like, you know, is there going to
be a CRISPR treatment that you can
just dial up in order in ten or 20
years? You know, where you can give
your you know, you can give your
stem cell, you know, clone embryo at
20 or 30 point IQ.
Right.
Right. And so and so.
So maybe on the other side of this
are like, you know, these.
Sort of super babies.
Right where we come out the.
Other side of this and we sort of
technically engineer ourselves.
You know, not.
Just the perpetuation of the
species, but like an upgrade of the
species where all of a sudden the
babies are all coming out, like,
much, much smarter.
Right.
And then, you know, as a consequence,
they're able to, you know, do all
kinds of things better, you know,
kind of through their lives, like,
you know, So maybe there's a
technological utopia on the other
side of this.
You know, on the other hand, maybe
this is some sort of catastrophic
moral choice, ethical.
Civilizational collapse, right.
Where we've given up on sort of the
inherent spirit of what it means to
be human.
And we're going to use you know,
we're just in like terminal decline
and we're you know, we're going to
use technology as sort of the cyber
part of it. We're going to use
technology as sort of a Band-Aid,
you know, to kind of cover up what
what otherwise is kind of a hard
crash.
Right.
I don't know. Like I don't know.
I will say, like, these issues
are real. Like, these issues are
real and they're forming up.
And, you know, everything you and.
I just talked about, like it's all
real. It's all going to happen.
And these are very big questions.
And, you know, either people do not.
Want to talk about them today or
they totally freaked people out.
People get really mad.
So at least I have yet to
read or hear a I don't know, I
guess what I would say is a clear,
dispassionate.
Non-ideological, like, you
know, full summation of all this
like.
And yeah, maybe what people are.
Bringing a lot of priors into this
conversation. It's a little hard to.
Yes.
Yeah.
Those are those sectors where
you think.
Where do you think that there's
currently
the right amount of investment?
Insufficient investment, Too much
investment because there's hype.
Where are we?
Where are we? There.
Yeah. So. Well.
So investment. So.
So. So the real answer to the
question is there's actually two
kinds of technology investment and
they're actually very different.
So there's, you know, the term that
gets used.
To call research and development.
But really, those are two different
things. So there's research and then
there's development. And those are
those are two different things.
And so.
The research is basically funding
into.
Scientific research.
And basically what that means is
funding into, you know, really smart
people.
Pursuing like really deep questions
around technology and science.
You know, such that, you know, they
may not even know what you know,
they may not have any idea yet of.
What commercial relevance or what
kind of product could get built on
it or even whether something can
work.
Right.
And so, you know, so.
It's the classic, classic concept of
basic research.
And then there's the other side of
it, which is what we.
Do, which is the development side.
Right. And so the way we.
Think about it is by the time we
fund.
A company to build a product like
the basic research has to be
finished already. Like there can't
be open basic research questions
because otherwise you have a startup
that you don't even know whether the
single ever actually be able to even
be able to build the thing.
But then also, like, it.
Needs to be close enough to
commercialization that, you know,
within like five years or something,
you can actually commercialize it
into a product. So.
So anyway, it's sort of fairly well.
Understood that those are the two
sides of things.
You know, that formula works really
well in the computer industry.
So there was.
50 years of basically government
research into information science,
computer science, you know,
during and after World War Two.
And then that translated to the
computer industry, software
industry, Internet. And that worked,
by the way, that also worked in
biotech. Right.
And so that works for, you know,
NIH, you know, had this big sort of
sustained biomedical research
program that resulted in the biotech
industry.
Which, you know.
Most recently resulted in things
like the M RNA vaccine.
So like that worked.
You know, those research programs
continue.
You know, those are.
The two main areas of, I think,
actual productive research
happening. So those are the two main
areas where we can get results out.
The other side.
You know, should there be more
funding in the basic research?
I mean, almost certainly there
should be.
You know, like having said that,
the.
Basic research world has a very
profound crisis underway right now,
which is this what they call the
replication crisis.
Which is it turns out that a lot of
what.
People thought was basic research
has actually just basically been
fake.
And.
Arguably fraud. And so there is a.
Among the many problems.
That our modern universities have,
there is a very big problem, or most
of the research that they're doing
does seem to be sanctions.
And so, you know, it's like,
what would you recommend more money
to.
Be put into a system that's just
generating fake results?
No.
Would you, though, argue that, like.
You do need basic research to
continue to get new products out the
other end? Yes.
So like that problem ought to
get dealt with.
Maybe it's starting to get maybe
it's starting to get dealt with very
slowly.
On the development side, I'm
probably more optimistic, I think.
Yeah, Generally, like I
would say generally we don't lack
for money, which is to say the
venture capital industry like my
industry, venture.
Capital funding of startups and
funding of new tech.
Like I would.
Say, we as a sector have plenty of
money. There's plenty of investors
who want to invest.
You know, the.
Companies seem to get perfectly well
funded.
I think basically all the good
entrepreneurs get funded.
I think that, you know, all the big
companies get funded.
I don't think there's a shortage of
money there.
The main question on that side of
things is not so much the money.
The main.
Question goes back to our question
about competition and how markets
work, which is.
In what fields of economic.
Activity can there actually be
startups?
Right?
And so and specifically, for.
Example, can you actually have
education startups?
Can you actually have healthcare
startups? Can you actually have
housing startups.
Or will they can you actually have.
Financial services startups?
Can you actually can you actually do
a new bank?
Like can you do a new online bank
that.
Like works in a different way?
And, you know, for for
those fields where you would want to
see.
Like a lot of progress.
The bottleneck is not whether we can
fund.
Them. The bottleneck is literally
whether the companies will be allowed
to exist.
And so on that.
Side of things, that that that's
what I would focus on.
Yeah, I think there are sometimes
places where you might have said,
Listen, it's settled wisdom that you
can't have a startup in this
area and then it turns out you
can. And I'm thinking here, I guess,
of space.
I'm thinking of,
you know, maybe to some extent in
some subsets of education.
And of course, also
I would put crypto in this category.
You know what?
How can you compete with money?
And then here we are in a quite
robust competitive market
that is trying to compete with
money.
What how do you how do you go from
actually competition doesn't look
very possible in that space to.
Someone tries it.
Yeah. So Space X is probably the
best. You know, Space X is probably
your best case scenario.
We talk about.
Crypto also as an example, but like
so let's just take space X as an
example, right?
So, you know, I mean, talk about a
market that's like dominated by the
government.
And like has regulated regulations
to the.
Moon, literally to the moon,
right? Like, you know, you know,
there has not you.
Know, it's one of these things that
have I don't even know the last time
anybody tried to do it, the launch
platform.
And then the idea.
That you're going to put all these
satellites
up there, like there's massive
regulatory issues around that.
So and then just like the
complexity, you know.
On top of that, you know, he, you
know, even.
Wanted the rockets to be reusable,
so he wanted them to, like, land on
the rear ends.
Right. Which is like something that
people thought was impossible.
Right. You know, all previous
rockets, you basically they're one
shot and they're done, whereas his
rockets get reused over and over
again because they're able to land
themselves.
And so, yeah, I mean, look at space
X climbed a wall of.
Skepticism its entire way and like
he basically just like brute force
his way through it and you know he
and the team there made it work.
And so that you know that's that's
the best case scenario that there is
a playbook that he used.
Which we have, you know, now.
Now that he now that he's done.
That to give him full credit, you
know, we've studied that playbook.
And so we're attempting to replicate
it in other fields.
You know, the big thing we.
Talk about there in our business is
just like.
You know what?
That is a much, much harder
entrepreneurial journey, right?
Like that. That's just like
what the.
Entrepreneur has to sign up for to
do.
That like and the.
Risks that are involved are just
like, much harder.
But like, you know, for example,
starting a new software company or
something.
And so it's just a much higher bar
of competence that's required.
It's just much higher risk.
You're going to lose more of those
companies because they're just going
to like not be able to make it.
They're going to get blocked in some
way.
And then you need a certain kind.
Of founder who's willing to take
that on.
And that founder looks a lot
like an Elon Musk or, by the way, it
looks like a Travis Kalanick.
Right? Or it looks like an Adam
Neumann. Right.
Or it looks like, you know, you
know.
These are the you know, or or by the
way, in the.
Past it looks like Henry Ford,
Right?
You know.
These this requires, you know.
Attila the Hun,
Alexander the Great Genghis Khan.
Right?
These are the you know, to make that
kind of company work.
Requires somebody who is so smart.
And so determined
and so.
Aggressive and.
So fearless.
Right. And so resistant to
injury of many different kinds.
Right. And so willing to take on
just like absolutely.
Cosmic levels of vitriol and
hate and abuse.
Right. And security threats and all
the other crazy stuff.
Like.
And so, you know, speaking of
growing people, we need more of
those people. I wish we could find
a.
Way to grow them attacks.
We don't know how to grow them.
Attacks.
You know, we spend a lot of.
Every day in our day job trying to
find those people.
You know, we call the problem the
missing Elance, Right?
It's just like, you know, we need
ten more aliens and then we.
Need a hundred more islands and then
we need a thousand islands.
And it's just like I can just tell
you, like there are not many islands
running around
and, you know, and you are like you
lot, you know, people have like, as
you well know, but like people have
all.
Kinds of reactions to island, like,
you know.
Like these people put up with, you
know, that look, you you've been
very successful. He's made a lot of
money.
So forth so like he puts up a lot of
ship from a lot of people on a lot
of topics.
That would cause most people to melt
into a little puddle.
And so this this is like the highest
engagement.
I mentioned the top of the top Gun
story, the top ten movies.
So Tom Cruise once said he said
there's Tom Cruise once had this
great quote. He said, there's only
it was he said there's only four
professions that are
really that are really like fully
masculine, that are like real.
Men should actually pursue.
And as he said, it's a.
Fighter pilot, rock star, movie star
and president.
Of the United States.
Right.
So, you know, in theory, he's done.
Three of those.
Two of those three, three of those,
if you count the movies.
That we have.
Because it depends on how you count
certain other people. Maybe you've
done more of those.
You know, maybe the fifth is,
you know, high octane entrepreneur,
right, operating in a.
Regulated industry who just is
determined to just like, punch
through the walls.
You know, you know, category number
five is Elon. And so anyway, I had
started like, this is the like in
our world, this is the prize.
Like, this is the prize.
We wake up every day hoping
actually.
A lot of work through the.
Door. Generally, we get very smart
entrepreneurs walking through the
door. They're really good at what
they do.
But they're not the next Dylan.
Every once in a while they ask us,
What would it take to be the next
CEO on?
And I describe what it would take.
And they get this like increasingly
disturbed look on their face and
then they kind of decide they don't
want to do that.
Is this kind of the classic like,
oh, if you have to ask the price,
you can't afford it situation?
Well, there's this question then,
which is like, are these people like
us? You know? Yeah, actually one of
the one example like, you know, you
know, nature versus nurture, right?
You know, who was he?
Was he was he born that way?
Was he trained that way?
Right. Culture, you know.
You know, you know, for sure.
He's like, you know, super smart.
You know, there's a big nature
component to that. He's super
disagreeable.
Right? He's maybe the most
disagreeable
person on the earth on planet Earth
right now. And if there's a bad guy,
you know, kind of nature component
to that.
Um, but then, look,
you know, he, he's, you know, he's,
he's articulate his life story Like,
there are plenty of things that
happen.
To him that caused him to develop an
incredibly thick shell and to be
incredibly determined to not want to
give up on.
And so, you know, a lot of.
That probably came from his, you
know, cultural, you know, sort of
cultural acculturated kind of
experiences traveling through.
Life.
And then, you know, like.
Part of it's just like simple, flat
out determination, Like he just
applies himself.
You know, with.
A level of effort and focus,
you know, And just every day,
you know, he works around the clock.
Like it's really amazing to watch.
You know.
I mean, we're used to workaholics
and he's like on a whole different
level.
And so, you know, I don't know.
Yeah, I could you know, could you
take more people who kind of have
the right, you.
Know, the right stuff, you know, in
terms of being smart and
disagreeable and intense and could
you train them up better?
Probably. You know, you know, we try
you know, that is.
Kind of what we try to do.
Um, you know, that said, like,
you know, there's something special
going on there.
Why do you think it is that there is
this kind of special category
of like
obsessive anger that's directed
at particularly the entrepreneurial
billionaire? I mean, we're talking
about, you know, U.S.
senators tweeting billionaires
should not exist.
Right. Like this is it's sort of
it's very acceptable to say it's a
widely shared view.
Um.
Where does that come from?
Why is it why is that like a meme in
our culture?
Yeah. So I think it's all in nature,
to be totally honest.
I think it's what he called
ressentiment, which
basically is it's basically it's
a it's what he called a toxic blend
of resentment, envy and bitterness.
And so it's it's sort of it's
the cornerstone.
Of sort of modern culture, right?
It's the cornerstone of Marxism.
It's the cornerstone of, you know,
progressivism. It's you know, it's
it's the cornerstone kind of thing,
which is like we resent you know, we
resent people who are better than
us.
You know, different societies are
different.
Christianity, too, right?
Yeah. Christianity, you know, the
last will be first and the first
will be last. You know, a rich man,
you know, you know, well.
Sooner pass through the eye of a
needle than enter the kingdom of.
God. Right.
Like, you know, you know,
Christianity is is is you know.
It's sometimes described as sort of
the final.
Religion. You know, Christianity is
described sometimes as the final.
It's the last religion.
That can ever exist on planet Earth,
because it's the one that appeals to
victims.
And the nature of.
Life is there are always more
victims than there are winners.
And so the victims are always the
majority. And so therefore, one
religion is going to capture all the
victims or all the people who think
of themselves as victims or want to
identify as victims.
And you know, that by definition is
the majority.
You know, among lower class
societies sometimes.
You know, lower class, you know,
social scientists sometimes refer to
a phenomenon called crabs in a
bucket where in
a lower class environment, if one
person starts to do better, the
other people will drag them back
down.
Right. You say this is like a big
problem in education, in lower class
environments, and one kid starts to
do good and the other kids start to
bully him until he is going back,
you know, until he's no better than
the rest.
Of Scandinavian culture, you know,
that I come out of it.
You know, there's a term.
Tall poppy syndrome.
Right?
You know, the tall poppy gets
whacked. You know, the the tall
poppy growing in the field, you
know, gets gets gets his head cut
off.
You know, the Japanese have their
own version of, you know.
This again, it's it's almost like a
cross. It's like a very deep.
Human nature thing.
It's basically just it's a very deep
level. It's envy and resentment.
And the you know, the nature of
envy and resentment is like
they're very satisfying
feelings, like, you know,
resentments.
Like a drug, Right?
Like resentment is a very satisfying
feeling because it's.
The feeling that lets us off the
hook.
Right?
Like, if I can.
Resent somebody.
Else, then. Then it's not my fault.
It's their fault. Not my fault.
I'm not bad.
They're bad, Right?
And if they're more.
Successful than I am, it just proves
that they're worse than I am.
Right. Because obviously they must
be immoral. They must have committed
crimes. They you know, they must be
making the world worse.
You know, they must be a destructive
force.
And so, yeah, it's like it's it's
very, very deeply wired in,
you know,
I guess I I'll say this, you know,
the entrepreneurs, the.
Best entrepreneurs we deal with,
they have no trace of it at all.
You know, the best entrepreneurs we
deal with, you know, with just the
things, the entire concept is just
absolutely ridiculous.
Like, why would I spend any minute
thinking about whatever anybody else
has done or whatever anybody else,
you know, thinks of me like that?
That's crazy.
Like, I'm just going to I'm going to
make progress my whole life today
and the rest of the rest of what
people think doesn't matter.
But yeah, the very nature of it.
I mean, look, you know.
You call it slavery, slave morality.
Right. Which is, you know, the
morality of the slave.
And of course, the irony of slave
morality is slave morality is, you
know, in the modern world is is
taken on primarily by people who are
not actually slaves.
Right. And so it's people who are
choosing to have the morality of the
slave, even though they actually
are.
They are even.
Though they actually are free to
also not do that.
And, you know, if you're if you're
immersed in that world or you've
been brought up in that world or
you've been trained into that world,
or it's reinforced your natural
inclination to be in that world,
it's really hard. You know, the
message that comes across that says,
no, actually.
No, actually the things that.
Are going wrong in your life are not
because other people are doing
better. That's because you're
screwing everything up.
Like, you know, who wants to hear
that?
What are you reading, watching,
listening to and
what do you think What what
new ish book is being slept
on right now? What's a newish book
that is good and underappreciated?
Oh, let's see. Well, so I mentioned
Burnham, so I. I can't help myself.
So for anybody
wanting to kind of really understand
kind of this like something we were
talking about earlier, about like.
The different models of capitalism.
You know, So there's kind of two
really key.
James Burnham books.
One is called The Managerial
Revolution, which,
you know, kind of describes the sort
of evolving shape of capitalism
through the 20th century, which I
think is probably the best
explanation for what happened to get
us where we are.
And then there's another.
Book called The Machiavellian, which
is about kind of the structure of
politics and society in
the sort of, you know, sort of
democratic world.
So those are really good on
nature. So I've actually been
reading my way.
All the way through both nature and
shopping power, which is very
interesting. But there's a.
Small book on the topic.
Of resentment we were just talking
about.
There was a philosopher in the 19
tens, 1920s named Max Shayler
who wrote a book called Ressentiment
Our SS Ressentiment,
Our SS, I estimate.
And he he
basically it's a short book, it's on
Amazon, and he basically describes
Nietzsche's Nature's.
Theory of Ressentiment,
which we just talked about, and then
he sort of elaborates on it
and.
And that's, that's really
you read that.
Book and you're like, Oh my God,
like, yes, I'm surrounded by people
just like that.
So there's that one.
What else?
Let's see. Give me a second here.
I just read it.
Have you run into John Murray
Cuddihy?
No.
If you're into this guy. So I just
read his two books. Very obscure.
Very well. They're both online.
You can get them both online on the
Internet.
Archive.
But they're they're sort of posted
there, sort of post Nietzsche, and
they're actually sort of on the
same.
Topics.
It's basically they're they're on.
The topic of basically what happens
when different societies basically
clash.
When societies encounter.
Each other, and then some societies
are more developed and other
societies, like some societies are
more like materially prosperous than
other societies. And basically like,
what is the reaction that happens
from that? And what are all of the
different coping mechanisms and
changes that happen as a result?
So history books are both fantastic
from the 1970s.
I'd recommend both of those.
More recent books.
Okay, I'll give you two. I'll give
you two that I think are sort of.
Flip sides of this.
Very interesting.
Some of the topics we talked about
earlier. So two books on sort
of the past and future of humanity
that I recommend. So the sort of
culture book is Joseph
Henrich wrote
the book.
On what he calls weird,
which is the book's called The
Weirdest People in the World and
Weird is this acronym of
Western educated, industrial, Rich
and Democratic.
And Henrik is like the leading
anthropologist.
Of his generation.
And he came up with this.
Very interesting breakthrough, which
is he came up with a way to
actually.
Critique different.
Cultures, but without being called
racist.
Or bigoted or xenophobic in the way
that he did. It was he came up with
this acronym, weird.
To describe our culture.
So it so it.
Sort of is this like basically this
little mechanism that he uses where
like, who can get mad at him for
calling our culture weird?
Like you say, it sounds like he's
being self-critical, but what he's.
Actually doing is it's actually a
very interesting kind of
X-ray of the process of cultural
development both in the West and
elsewhere. That's really
interesting.
And, you know, there are still.
Huge cultural differences all around
the world that,
you know, that are still very
relevant
that he goes through in a lot of
detail.
It's probably is probably the best
work of like cultural.
Analysis written since, like
probably, I don't know, the 1950s or
maybe 1930s or something, because
you figured out a way to actually
kind of talk a little bit more
openly.
About it.
One other thing, I read that
and I really did not think
when I opened it up that I was going
to be learning that much about
cousin marriage.
But it turns out that's a big one in
their.
Cousin marriage, cousin, marriage.
And as okay so we'll do a minor
spoiler. So cousin marriage
turns out to be a really big deal
because societies that have cousin
marriage basically cousin marriage
is the mechanism.
For the perpetuation of a tribal
society.
And so the way that.
Tribes perpetuate and basically
maintain sort of the coherence of
the tribal identity and the
tribal kind of.
Feeling, the way that they do.
That is basically through cousin
marriage. They basically have enough
intermarriage among cousins where
the tribe sort of the.
Barrier.
Between the tribe and the rest of
the world actually kind of remains
intact.
And then.
The theory that he goes through is
basically.
What what happened in the West.
That caused the West to diverge, you
know, with the Enlightenment and
with modern economic development and
scientific development and
everything else that's happened the
last 500 years.
The thing.
That caused the West to change and
become what it is today is that the
Catholic Church banned cousin
marriage.
In Europe, which they did for their
own self-interest.
They did because it turns out they
wanted the money.
In his theory.
They wanted the bequests, they
wanted the money. They didn't want
money. The Catholic Church did not
want money to stay in families.
It wanted the families to basically
fracture over time so that the money
would go back to the church.
But the result of that was like.
In his argument.
That was that the change in human
affairs that led to the
Europe transitioning from being a
tribal society to what it is today,
which you could call an enlightened
society called atomized society.
Right.
You know, it led to the rise of the
concept of essentially the modern.
Concept of the individual, you
know, which is still an alien
concept in a lot of tribal
societies. So so that was
really interesting.
And then and then
the sort of other the flip side of
that on the sort of
sort of.
Genetic side, which is super
interesting, is this book called Who
We Are and How We Got Here,
which is this is a Harvard
professor, David Reich, who runs
the leading lab that does this work
in archeology called ancient DNA,
where it turns out we now have the
science to basically find like a
skeleton that's thousands of years
old. And these scientists actually
know how to extract DNA.
And.
Actually analyze and actually
analyze the DNA. And this you know,
this is like a huge breakthrough in
archeology work for obvious reasons.
And so Reich is.
REICH It's Reich in his lab at
Harvard are actually
they.
Are actually building.
Out the actually the actual human
family tree.
So the actual.
Genealogy of the human race.
And.
Why and it's why the book is called
Who We Are and How We Got.
Here. Like, it literally is.
Like the actual genealogy of human
race, like where all these people
came from, like how we all got
descended from whatever, you know,
all these questions and then how all
the populations developed and how
they intermixed or how they didn't
intermix and so forth.
And it's just like and I
just found that to be like an
absolutely it feels like an X-ray
machine out of the ancient world
through science, through modern
cutting edge science that I found
completely unexpected.
Oh, and then I'll I'll add one.
Final book, which is the best book
of cults that I've ever read, which
is also relevant on the same.
Right.
Which is the ancient city.
Which is this book that was written
in the 1860s by this
French scholar at the time.
And it's sort of a.
It's actually it's actually
interesting. He he he used
a literary method.
So this guy in the 1860s
basically apparently read all
original.
Greek and Roman literature, like
apparently read all of it.
And then he derived from it
basically what human.
Civilization was like before the
Greeks and Romans.
And so what it was actually like.
To basically be in a tribe
or be in a family, to be in a tribe
or be in a city in
like 2000, 3000 B.C., 4000
B.C., 5000 B.C.
And then sort of the changes
happened over time. And then what
actually happened when Greece and
Rome arrived.
And if you read those three books
together, it's like you
get this kind of cultural analysis
side.
You get this archeological society.
Then you get this like literary
analysis side of like painting a
picture of what the world used to be
like.
Which is not like.
The world is today.
And it's actually been very helpful
for me to understand what the world
is like today, kind of as a as a
as a derivation of how people used
to live that.
Anyway, Among other things that.
The ancient city talks about as it
talks about the critical role of the
cult.
And the religion.
Basically the cult literally being
a religious cult, literally being
like the foundational model for for
human lives prior to what we now
know as religions.
And so also, if you find yourself in
the business of wanting to create
cults, it turns out to be a good
book.
You know, there are days it's
tempting.
So, you know, at that same point ten
years ago when you were making that
prediction, I, a perhaps
naive libertarian,
had a lot of hopes that
the these technologies would
be would finally be the thing
that that took
a bunch of our commerce
and a bunch of our networks
of trust outside of the
realm of the state, or at least
another degree removed.
And I think.
Some of that was punctured quite
quickly. This idea that Bitcoin is
anonymous, right.
Which was just never true.
But I wonder what your
what your sense is of whether
ultimately there is still that kind
of liberatory element
to these technologies.
Is there is there good reason
to think that we will live in a
free society when some of these
things come to fruition?
Or do we take
the the cynical realists
view that the regulators always have
their way?
Yeah. So I think I, I think
economic freedom.
I think you can I think you can make
that argument so quite strongly.
Political freedom, you know, maybe,
maybe not.
So the economic freedom argument is
just like it's the same argument.
You make on the Internet, which is
like, are people more economically
free on the Internet than they used
to be in an old world is just having
stories. And I think the answer is
clearly yes. Like people have the
ability to offer goods and services
much more broadly. They have the
ability to buy from many more
places.
You know.
Transparency of what people are
buying is much greater now than it
used to be.
You know, reputation matters more
than just, you know, whatever
happens to be on the store shelves.
So and then, you know, people can.
Transact in, you know, categories of
goods and services that maybe would
have been hard to get out in the
past. You know, so there's a whole
bunch of, like economic freedom
arguments.
Does that translate to political
freedom?
You know, so the state.
There's a couple of things, right?
The state is sort of.
Obvious, but just.
To make the argument, right.
So the state does have like one
fundamental thing.
That's just hard to get away from,
which is it just it has territory,
like it has physical territory and
then it has the ability to tax on
that territory.
And so to the extent that you need
to live anywhere, you're going to
be.
Living someplace and that place is
going to want its share of your
economic output, you know, your
economic output.
And they're going to show up.
You know, the tax collector is going
to show up. When the tax collector
shows up, he's going to want to get
paid in his currency.
Right. And so oil again, by having a
body.
Precisely.
Exactly. So the tax,
if you're in the as the tax
collector, is going to.
Want U.S. dollars.
If you're in France, the you know,
the tax collector is going to want
whatever currency they use these
days.
And, you know, so I
do believe, like there's all these
there's all these theories of what
makes money, money.
And one of the.
Theories I like is John Law's
theory, which is money, is that
which people trade with.
And the theory there basically is
people will always find some sort of
thing. So they'll always find
something, whether it's cow shells
or scrap currency or or
US dollars or diamonds
or art or bitcoin that they
ought to trade with.
So money as facilitation for
trading, I do believe that.
But having said that, there's
another theory of money.
As money as that which the sovereign
taxes you for.
Because you need to get whatever
that is, you need to get some of
that. Like even if you want to live
in an all.
Bitcoin world in the U.S.
today, you at some point you to
convert to dollars because you need
to pay your taxes and the IRS does
not take bitcoin.
So so I kind of think those are
both.
Pretty pretty solid solid.
Theories and to me those kind of
argue.
For both sides of it which is, yeah,
you're going to have systems that
are going to facilitate trade that
are not necessarily, you know, the
U.S. dollar or the euro or the yen.
You're going to you're going to have
you know, you're going to have
online alternatives to those.
And you do today.
And look, Bitcoin has been trading
and.
Being used for transactions
continuously every minute of every
day since 2009.
Right.
And so those are going to exist.
But at the same time, like, yeah.
We do have physical bodies, at least
for.
Now, we're going to be routed.
Someplace, at least for now.
The tax collector is going to show
up, at least for now.
You know, look, there's big
outstanding regulatory issues right
now in the whole space.
You know, there's that.
And we're back to the original
regulation discussion that we had,
which is just like there's tons of
push and pull. There's lots of
people who think that there ought to
be more regulations in this space.
There's tons of people who think
that there shouldn't be.
There is the theory of enlightened
regulation.
That will achieve the results that
the regulators have had.
And then there's the reality of the
unintended.
Consequences that.
Always come with it. We're back to
that exact same dynamic in
crypto regulation.
You know, sitting here today, both.
In the.
In the U.S. and around the world.
You know, I don't know, like.
And then there's, like, you know,
another way to think.
About this is like, you know, it's
constant. You know, the surface
level kind of question is always
just why aren't they just going to
ban it? Right? Like, so there's
banned Bitcoin and then it's like,
well, how do you ban Bitcoin?
It's like it's it's an algorithm.
Like it's it's an algorithm, which
means it's a mathematical formula.
The source code for it is available
for free. Anybody can download and
run that source code on their
computer, you know, for
the government to, you know, for any
government to ban Bitcoin, you know,
they literally are putting themselves
in a position where they're banning
mass.
You know, they're banning code,
you know, like they can try,
you know, the level
of I would say the level of tyranny.
Required to ban math
is, I think, way in excess,
practically speaking, of what
governments are either capable of
doing or actually want to do, like
the North Koreans can probably do
it.
I don't know.
I don't know that our government.
Would be allowed to do it even by
people who think that this stuff
should be.
Regulated.
So, yeah, you
know, look, I think there's going to
be some running room for for.
For innovation here.
I also make a very different
argument on this, which a lot of.
People respond to, which is, look.
This is a.
Technology of the future.
Like at least like those
of us who are those of us whose
job it is.
To like.
Identify technologies of the future
and help build them.
Like this is one of those like
everybody, everybody in my.
World who's like, really smart.
They're all like, yes, this this is
a technology. The future, what exact
shape it takes is is open question.
But yeah, this is a big deal.
30 years from now, this is going to
be a really big deal.
And a lot of the smartest computer
science people in the industry have
gone into this field and are working
hard on making it work and making it
better.
And then it's like, okay, if there
is going to be.
A technology of the future.
When it's.
Back to the question you asked about
AI earlier.
Would we like that.
Technology of the future to be built
and developed and housed in the
United States, or
would we prefer to drive it offshore
to other places?
And actually Rishi Sunak in the UK
just came out with a very supportive
statement policy, basically
essentially saying if you as
regulators don't want the stuff in
the US that everybody's just come to
the UK and do it there.
You know, so, so maybe.
There'll be an escape hatch to the
UK, you know, maybe to Singapore or
someplace like that.
You know, or you know, I don't know
or people will come to their.
Senses and understand that they
should, you know, this is something
the
country should actually invest in to
support or there
will be attempts to regulate it and
they just won't work.
Well, and I don't know, you
know.
Those are all open questions right
now.
This was great.
Is there anything else that you
think reason readers should know?
But what else?
What message do you have for the
people?
Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
Here would be something. It's just
like, Yeah, I would say, try
the new stuff. Right?
Like, you try it, right?
Like, you know, find a friend, you
know, find a friend who has a.
Tesla and, you know, take it for a
ride with the full self-driving,
turn it on.
Right. Or like, you know, chat,
chat, log in to chat.
Online and like, log in to create an
account, try it or, you know, you
know, try, try a.
Yeah, just like, you know, these
things, you know, these most of.
These things, you can just like go
online and either for, you know,
trivial amounts of money or no money
you can just try and use.
I just, you know, there's there's
just oceans and.
Oceans and oceans of commentary on
this stuff.
You know, not not.
Not you guys, but like from lots of
other sources. And like for most of
it, it's just, you know, we out here
just like shake our head being like
these people have even use this
stuff like, you know, they're
they're debating shadows on the cave
wall.
You know, this is a longstanding
point that we make about guns.
Yeah. There's a lot of people who
have never shot a gun, who have
a lot of opinions about guns.
Every time you read about, like, you
know, automatic pistols, right?
It's like,
you know, it's like, okay, go shoot
a pistol
over, trigger it out.
Let's see what happens.
Yeah, exactly.
So, yeah, look,
the tech industry, the tech the tech
industry used to be top down, so the
tech industry used.
To create products for like the
government first and then big
companies second, and then small
companies third and then regular
people.
And in the last 20 years, that's
reverse the tech industry.
Now everything new.
That matters comes out for people.
First, it's the.
Consumer markets lead, and then it's
like years.
Later, big companies and governments
start to figure out how to how to
deal with this stuff. And so.
Anything new and.
Interesting is something that you
can literally just log on and try.
And it's all, yeah, the
water. Yeah, the water is warm
on this end of the pool.
Like this stuff is actually stuff
that's actually pretty cool.
Thank you for talking to reason.
You're awesome. Thank you for having
me.